so the 2015 Iran nuclear deal has
survived for more than four years but
only just it was signed by Iran and six
nations led by the US under President
Barack Obama in a deal to lift sanctions
in exchange for monitoring of to Iran's
nuclear activities less than a year
later has at a Donald Trump withdrew
from the agreement and he reimpose
sanctions while other nations tried to
keep the pact alive but following
another wave of tough US sanctions in
May last year Iran began rolling back
its compliance first it increased its
stockpile of enriched uranium and on
Sunday after the u.s. killing of its top
military commander to her on suspended
limits on uranium enrichment and nuclear
research as well as development let's
talk about this with Ellie
guren Mya she's a senior policy fellow
at the European Council of Foreign
Relations she's joining us via Skype
from London thanks very much for your
time with us on the al Jazeera news hour
so what role do you think that you can
actually play in mediating this crisis
[Music]
and they have been trying their best to
preserve at least the architecture of
this Agreement in place to prevent a
nuclear crisis emerging in parallel to
this military escalation that we're
seeing between the u.s. and Iran I think
a second area where there may be
European role to play is by actually
playing a direct mediator role between
Washington and Tehran the Europeans have
direct access to both capitols some of
the key figures in Europe like President
have had endless hours of thermals with
both presidents rouhani and president
Tom over the past year and they could
play a strong role to creating this
longer extended cooling-off period
between the two sides after this
military resignation right but which
leverage I understand what you're saying
about the Europeans having a stake in
this deal but how much leverage do the
Europeans actually have because the
Iranians seem to criticize the European
saying that they just haven't done
enough to salvage this deal
ever since the u.s. presidents withdrew
[Music]
there's not a huge amount of leverage in
instance that they can have in this game
but you know let's not forget that Iran
at the same time as withdrawing from its
commitments under the nuclear deal has
explicitly not with phone from the
agreement all together and has left the
door open for some sort of diplomatic
initiative particularly from the
Europeans who have a degree of influence
with Washington and you trying to pull
both sides out of this escalatory cycle
that we see at the moment what about go
ahead please to a limited extent as well
the Europeans could have an economic
role to play obviously companies across
Europe have taken a major setback
because of us secondary sanctions but
there are still some creative works in
the pipeline regarding how some degree
of trade between Iran and Europe can
continue regardless of the US sanctions
architecture and let me ask you about
the Iranians step on Sunday whether I
say they would no longer be abiding by
limits set on how many centrifuges they
can use to enrich uranium yet at the
same time the Foreign Minister Mohammad
Javad Zarif said that the move was a
remedial step and it is reversible so
are the Iranians themselves keeping the
door open for diplomacy
that that their actions are reversible
as long as the other parties to the
agreement can fulfill their parts of the
commitment so far neither the Europeans
will frankly the Chinese or the Russians
have been able to provide Iran with a
substantive economic package that can
compensate the major hit that the
Iranian economy has taken after the u.s.
brought back in sanctions so that's one
area but I think the second area that we
should be aware of is that everybody now
is more shaking and the clock ticked up
up until the November elections in the
United States and I think one part of
the strategy so far for the Europeans
and the Iranians is to keep at least the
shell of the nuclear deal in place until
November when I think everybody will
have to make some critical decisions if
they are in fact facing another four
years of the Trump administration all
right we'll have to leave it there we
thank you very much for speaking to us
from London